we've seen that an investment bank can
buy a bunch of mortgages which
essentially makes them the lender to the
homeowners and then it could stick those
mortgages inside of a special-purpose
entity and then it could sell the shares
in that special-purpose entity and that
these shares would be called
mortgage-backed securities and let's
just say just for the sake of argument
when it sells these shares it sells them
at ten dollars ten dollars a share and
it promises dividends that's at ten
dollars a share the equivalent of a of
an eight percent of an eight percent
yield so maybe the more the the
homeowners here are paying a higher than
eight percent Interest some of them
default lets you average everything out
and the investment bank keeps a little
bit for itself and to up to do all the
operations and all the overhead and so
it can actually give the investors in 8%
yield this might be good for a whole
class of investors they might like the
safety profile the risk profile of the
special purpose entity of this
mortgage-backed security and they might
like the return and they might go for it
but there might be a class of investors
may be very risk-averse event investors
like pensions that says that this
mortgage-backed security is - is too
risky they've looked at what we're
holding and they're like hey some of
these are subprime mortgages some of
these are shady some of these are too
risky borrowers I don't like where this
is going and even if they can't look
under the hood to see what this is the
investment bank might have hired a
ratings agency so maybe so ratings
agency ratings agency to essentially
look under the hood and tell investors
what's there so the rating agency might
look at this special-purpose entity and
look at these securities and say look I
would say that these securities should
be rated these securities should be
rated BB so not super safe but not super
risky either but for pensions that is
not safe enough now on the other hand
you might have people who want more risk
so you might have maybe there are some
risky hedge funds and not all hedge
funds are risky but let's say that there
are some risky hedge funds and that they
say that this yield is too low yield is
too low and the the investment bankers
they're very creative people they say
well look here's some people who want to
buy securities but they're - these
securities are too risky for them
and there's other people who want to buy
securities who are able to take on more
risk but they say the yield is too low
so instead of losing out on these
investors why don't I just split up the
special-purpose entity in a different
way
why don't I split it up into tranches so
instead of all of the securities being
the same why don't I put them into
classes so why don't I put them into
classes and they're so often called the
senior tranche the senior tranche the
mezzanine tranche I'll just write meds
for shorter the middle tranche and then
the equity tranche and the way it works
in a mortgage-backed security everyone
gets paid the same amount in a in this
situation when you split it this way the
holders of the senior tranche securities
are going to get paid first only when
they're made whole are the owners of the
mezzanine tranche city is going to get
paid and only when they are made whole
will the owners of the equity tranche
security get played will get paid and
this scenario right over here is called
a collateralized debt obligation see do
and it's really a derivative security
from the mortgages we've sliced it and
dice it in a slightly different way now
you might be saying how does this solve
the problem
well now the ratings agency will will
say well look if the senior people are
going to get paid before everyone else
then I'm going to give them a higher
rating and they can even get insurance
on this and get a credit default swap
and then maybe they'll give it a
triple-a rating and which means that the
pensions can now buy the senior rated
CDOs and it and but they'll pay them
less interest maybe they'll pay them 5%
maybe the mezzanine they get paid next
they'll get maybe a still a double B
rating and they'll get the 8% and then
the equity tranche they'll get a higher
interest so they'll get they'll get say
a 15% interest in exchange for being the
last person to get paid and maybe they
don't get any ratings at all so you can
almost view this as a junk rating if you
want to view it that way but that makes
both people happy pensions get something
safe go lower yield hedge funds get
something risky but it has a higher
yield